la parole est à notre collègue jean
pierre vial pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue prime chez brillant alors
messieurs les ministres mois la question
est à l'intention de monsieur le milieu
intérieur en qualité d'élu de la région
rhône alpes et plus particulièrement
d'un des trois départements considérés
comme sensibles au sol de notre région
nous sommes bien évidemment et tout
particulièrement été affolés par les
récents événements de saint quentin
fallavier et m'associer bien évidemment
aux propos tenus à l'instant pour notre
collègue montaugé face à une situation
dont les actes montrent tous les jours
un peu plus la gravité et l'ampleur nous
ne pouvons qu'adhérer soutenir le
discours volontariste du prénom de la
république et de vous-même monsieur le
ministre nous ne pouvons qu'adhérer
également à déclaration du premier
ministre concernant son engagement total
contre le salafisme des frères musulmans
mais derrière cette déclaration
d'intention permettez moi de vous
interroger concrètement sur certains
aspects de la politique du gouvernement
au moment où le parlement bien de
débattre du texte de la sécurité en
sachant le rôle de premier important
joué par internet et les réseaux sociaux
concernant les salafistes le
gouvernement tunisien vient de réagir
fermement à la suite des derniers
événements en décidant la fermeture de
80 de ski salafistes or nous avons en
france un nombre x vie équivalent
d'établissement de lieux de prière
concernant les frères musulmans nous
connaissons les mesures prises et
envisager à leur égard par plusieurs
pays de la méditerranée pour sortir de
la radicalité de leurs discours or non
seulement aucune position semblable est
affichée en france à l'égard
d'organismes ou d'établissement qui
relève clairement de la doctrine des
frères musulmans mais au même moment la
position du quai d'orsay sont bien
différentes des propos du premier
ministre dans les alliances et
stratégies déployées au moyen-orient en
un mot la position du brillant la
république de vous-même ministre
l'intérieur du premier ministre ne
peuvent qu'obtenir notre soutien total
mais encore convient-il que le
gouvernement nous précise sa politique
face aux décisions à prendre et aux
contradictions constatée entre la
politique intérieure affichée et
certaines orientations de la politique
étrangère du gouvernement
pour vous répondre un parent le vin
messieurs bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le sénateur votre
question est pour moi l'occasion de
faire un point extrêmement précis sur un
certain nombre de sujets que vous avez
évoquées qui relève d'ailleurs pour
beaucoup de question de politique
intérieure de lutte contre le terrorisme
à l'intérieur de nos frontières je veux
parler de la lutte contre les formes de
radicalité et contre notamment les
radicalité violente qui peuvent
s'exprimer en appelant à la haine en
provoquant terrorisme dans un certain
nombre le deathmatch numérique ou dans
les mosquées que faisons nous d'abord
vous avez d inquiétude sur la
détermination qui est la nôtre a procédé
à l'expulsion de ceux qui profèrent ses
propos il ya non seulement une fermeté
totale mais tout ce qui d'après les
services de renseignement ou les
services de police se livrent à la
provocation de propos appelant à la
haine provoquant au terrorisme sont
systématiquement expulsés je veux
d'ailleurs pour vous rassurer vous
donner des chiffres depuis 2012 ce sont
40 expulsion de prêcheurs de haine qui
sont intervenus depuis le début de
l'année 2015 c'est dix dossiers
d'expulsions qui sont quasiment abouti
si ces expulsions sont déjà prononcés et
22 dossiers en instance pendant la même
période
du quinquennat précédent alors que le
risque était très élevé comme en
témoigne la ferme et rahou d'autres
affaires c'est 15 expulsion qui sont
intervenus en cinq ans là où nous en
avons fait 40 ans 3 ans et je ne céderai
pas face à ceux qui sont des
propagateurs de haine dans le pays ils
n'ont pas à s'ils sont étrangers leur
place en france ils seront expulsés
premier point la déchéance de la
nationalité vous en parlait souvent la
déchéance de la nationalité les six
déchéance est une procédure juridique
très complexe
depuis de 2012 il y en aura d'autres
pour tous ceux qui ont la double
nationalité et qui se livrent à la
propagation de discours de haine dans le
pays il y a aujourd'hui aussi des
dossiers en un stand et à main ils iront
à leur terme troisièmement les mosquées
salafistes
il y a des règles de droit elles sont
dans notre constitution et nous liait
l'union européenne s'il ya des
associations qui dans leur entièreté
dans les mosquées contribuer à la
dimension de pensée de l elles seront
dissoutes j'ai indiqué qu'il y avait des
dossiers en cours d'examen au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur mais le seront
dans le respect des règles du droit
constitutionnel
et du droit européen
parce que ne pas le faire reviendrait à
lutter contre le terrorisme dans
l'abandon des valeurs de la république
donc je vous le redis la fermeté du
gouvernement est totale prétendre le
contraire ne correspond pas à la réalité
de ce que nous faisons et cette fermeté
je l'exprimerai à chaque instant sans
trêve y pose face aux risques
terroristes merci monsieur le ministre